hey all it's energy catch here in this
tuesday video we're actually not going
to be looking
at this week's data set instead i wanted
to focus more on
actually generating or finding our own
data
so one of the most popular ways of
grabbing your own data is through web
scraping
and a very popular library in python is
called beautiful soup
however r has r vest which is basically
the alternative to it
and what's also good about it is it's a
part of the tidy verse
so i know a lot of you guys want me to
make more videos on tidy models
and and i'm actually working on a post
hoc
tidy models um video where we basically
analyze
like how to select the best optimal
model and also do um
class probability estimations however
i'm still working on it so this week i
figured i'd make a
shorter video on you know web scraping
your own stuff
so one of the other main components of
arvest
is the selector gadget um extension on
chrome
and this will allow us to basically
select the things we want to grab
so one of the main inspirations that i
got from
uh doing some web scraping is i was
reading 538
and i was reading their slack check um
articles where they basically post all
their slack chats
and i thought it'd be a kind of a fun
project to basically analyze
each um i guess editor or reporter's
dialogue because it's essentially
labeled data
so i looked at their website and saw
that they had a tag for slack chat
and that'd be cool to basically go
through every slack chat article
and extract all of the dialogue from it
with
the labeled reporters and editors
so that's what we're going to do i'm
going to open up a
our markdown file so our markdown i'm
going to call this
tidy tuesday 5 5 38 oops
5 5 3 8
and we're going to start loading in our
data sets or actually our libraries
so i'm going to do library
library tidy first
um was it arvest
and we'll load that in so when i was
looking at it
what we can see is we have these tags
for slackchat and we also have the next
page so when i click on next
we can see that there's pages for all of
the slack chat articles
um one thing that i need to know is um
how many pages there actually are
so i'm just going to go to say 50 see if
there's 50.
there's no 50 solid just divided we have
25
how about if we have 30
okay so what if we have uh
12 maybe there's 27 pages let's try that
nope let's try 26.
okay so it seems that there's about 25
pages
maybe we'll try again 26.
okay so there's 25 pages which is pretty
useful for us so we can just kind of
make this into a
5 30 8 slack pages
uh and then we'll just say table and say
pages
is equal to 1 to 25. okay
and then once our 538 pages slot page we
have our 538
slack pages we can just mutate and say
like i know
uh page link and we'll say uh
paste zero oops
and then we'll replace the 26 with
a page what is it actually i'll say a
page
num page num and then we'll say
page and then we'll give it page num
and then we'll give it a dash so now we
have our page and our page num
great so we'll put that into that
and we'll just say like um create the
uh pages of articles to scrape
great so
when we have our actual pages what we
need to do now is
um if we go to say was it one
um if we go to one we want to start
grabbing all these links so we can then
go into each link and grab all the text
so one this is one way to do it is just
using the selector gadget tool
or we can basically click on that um we
can also
uh press uh click on things that we uh
we want to deselect so for example i
don't want to
select the links for the podcast so
you're going to select that so
we also see that there's some more stuff
if you hold i think control
and then click on it it'll still it'll
remove other stuff
i also want to remove this so now we
have
all of these things that we want to
select so these are about
1 2 3 4 5 6
7 8 9 10 links
okay so what we need to do
is basically i'm gonna paste that and
what i like to do is i'm just gonna
um i'm gonna use this wait let me say uh
page 25 i'll say page one i'm to use
this as like kind of a tester thing
so i'll say page is that
so we have our page and one thing that
we have to do is convert this to our
html
so we'll say read html
and give that to a page if we look at it
it'll be kind of like html body so after
that we can now
um start grabbing our our data so the
first thing we do is
we just say html nodes which is
basically the stuff
that we were clicking on so these are
the nodes of this html page
highlighted in yellow so in this case
we're going to grab this stuff
and if we do this that means it's
starting to web scrape
and what we can see is we have all these
nodes which href which are our actual
links
so if we look on html attributes
and then we just say href it'll grab all
the links
and since we have 10 links this makes
sense
great um what i'm also going to do is
i'm going to convert this to a table
and we have that um
yeah so i'll also i'll say rename
uh value is eq value is equal to
uh link links uh what is it
oh maybe it's links is equal to uh value
right so now we have our links so after
i'm just gonna
put wrap this into a function so i'll
say get
links and i'll say function and we'll
just say the function will be
inside a page and then we'll just put
this
into that
cool so this is our uh so we'll say like
create a function to
grab the links
okay so what we'll also do now is
look at our 538 pages
and then we'll say mutate and say uh
we'll say what is it
links is equal to map give it our page
and then say get
links and we'll assign it to
our original data frame okay so let's
say
scrape the links
okay so now that we've scraped our links
we can look at our thing
and we have our our links if we do our
own nest
uh was it oops i nest
links we have all of our links with the
page numbers
etc so i'm just gonna assign that to our
data frame so now that we have our
our our links i'm just going to select
this the first one
and we can go to this
and this is a pretty easy thing to
scrape so i'm just going to load up the
selector gadget i'm going to click on
these things
we have all the text that we want to
select maybe we want to deselect that
stuff
what else do we want to deselect
uh maybe we want to deselect that if
that'll cause any problems and i think
that's fine
so there's also this but i think we can
get away with it
okay so now that we have that i'm just
gonna put this into
say so now we have our links i'm gonna
call this into like a page
i guess so we're just gonna reuse the
page oops i'm gonna
comment that out
so i'm going to use the first page
put that into it and then we'll say was
it
page is to read html
page and then what we'll do is we'll say
uh was it html
nodes and the html nodes we want to grab
is this thing
oh html nodes so we
and then what we can maybe do is html
was it text
okay so this didn't work so maybe we can
uh
change it up let's see if we can just
scrape it
in a general fashion like just with the
p
okay so we have that
interesting
maybe let's see here how what else can
we do
it's running into an error so let's
let's
let's figure out what's going on maybe i
need to select the actual
we have that we have this
interesting
so okay let's see what's going on here
hmm
i'm gonna i'm just gonna suck this again
it should work let's see if
p works again h page
okay so let's do page boom
html oops
hm nodes
read html page oh that's why so we had a
space there and it was causing an
error okay so let me actually try out
see if this will remove anything that i
don't want
great so now we have all this text
what i'm actually gonna do is i'm gonna
put that into a table
and one thing that i see that's uh
a a nice pattern is that the characters
or the
the was it the employees of 538 are
separated through a colon
so what i'm going to actually do is i'm
going to say i'm going to use the
separate function and say separate
and say value and then into staff
member and then text the separation will
be a
colon but also what i'm going to say is
extra
is equal to merge this is basically so
if they
if these people use a colon it won't
separate into another thing
so it it's only going to find the first
colon and i'll split it
okay so if we do that we have our thing
right so we have that text sometimes
there's going to be
a i guess a
unknown so let me see if that's uh if
that makes sense
okay so it it seems to be putting these
things as uh they're separate things
but that's fine um maybe i'll try a p
just to make sure it doesn't if it fixes
it
okay is there frost postponing the
election
nope so it does it does the same thing
so we're just going to keep it like this
great i think that's fine for right now
um we can definitely do some string
manipulation
but we're not going to worry about that
right now so i'm going to put this i'm
going to put this into a function so get
text
i'll say function and we just give it a
page and we're going to paste this in
one useful thing that we can also do is
we can use
what's called the um progress package
since there's gonna be a lot of um
there's gonna be 250
um pages that we're gonna be uh
scraping it's probably useful to look at
the progress so what i'm going to do is
actually i'm going to
um uh let's see where i'm going to do
this
okay so i'm going to do that so i'm
going to say
create a function to extract
text but i'm also going to load in the
what's it called the
progress package
and with the progress package is it
basically allows us to add
in a progress bar so i'm going to say
i'm gonna just add in a progress bar
which is generally denoted as pb
say progress bar
new and then the total so this is the
amount of um
out of like uh processes that it's gonna
try to track so our processes is what
we're gonna be scraping or the total
amount of pages we're gonna be scraping
which is gonna be the end row of the
538 packages
you can also add a format to it so i'll
say format is equal to
say executing uh we'll give it a
loading bar and we'll say percent
and also give like an eta okay
so we have that and then in the actual
function
all uh oops i'll just throw
throw that and i'll just give it what
it's called a
tick and then i'll do give it
assist.sleep
great so then i'll do that
okay cool so now what i'll say is
uh scrape the actual text
so i'm going to call this uh i guess
i'll just put it this on the 538 pages
so i'll say
538 and then i'll say
was it mutate and say
result is equal to map and then i give
it
what is it what do i what did i call it
again
uh oh links and get
text and i'll assign it to our 538 thing
okay so maybe
what's you did i do it pb tag pb
so now it's gonna be running oh let's
see here
okay so it just ran
five to eight pages and then we have our
results and let's do the unness results
great so now we have all of our text
into that i'm not sure why our get
text thing wasn't working with the the
pb
let me look at function page pb
tick
oh well um so yeah this is a pretty
quick video
but um this is basically how to do you a
really basic web scraping
um it's pretty easy um you basically
have to focus on the html nodes and then
your html attribute
in general if you're just gonna grab the
actual text you just use html text
so i know it's a pretty quick video but
i just wanted to do it um it's probably
even though it's uh
pretty simple it's probably the most
powerful thing to learn and it's
probably one of the most useful things
you'll actually do
in your data science projects so i'll
see you guys next week and tidy on